- I am British.
I ask people to say that because sometimes
the accent is confusing to Americans.
You'll be like, "Oh my
God, he's Australian."
(audience laughing)
"I love Australians."
So we're very different,
Australia and England,
very different countries.
I think the main difference
is that in Australia,
they have a saying, if
you see a very sexy woman,
they say "I would crawl
across a mile of broken glass
to suck the dick of the
last guy who fucked her."
(audience laughing)
That is what they all say.
And in England, we don't say that.
(audience laughing)
We say, "God, save the queen."
That's what we say.
"God save the queen."
That's our motto.
My gosh, the lights, wow.
That joke was so hard they're
having an epileptic fit,
this is good.
(audience laughing)
I'm not entirely sure
we're allowed to do this,
there wasn't a sign on the door
that said "The show may contain seizures."
(audience laughing)
"And a British man."
Is that like an emergency warning
on your phone or something?
Where they're like "Rip tide alert."
(audience laughing)
Okay, cool,
my set is now brought to
you by the makers of MDMA,
let's get ravey.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
I feel that there are
comedians that would benefit
from a light show behind them.
I don't think my mild
mannered British humor is.
(audience laughing)
Oh my gosh, you appeared from nowhere.
Fucking hell.
(audience laughing)
This is amazing.
Do you want to talk us
through what's going on here?
Other than the health and safety violation
of you trying to trip me up from behind
like this was a playground.
(audience laughing)
Well so you've got one of them off.
Okay, I'll tell jokes about tea.
(audience laughing)
No, no.
Are you British?
No, you were just cheering
at the concept of tea, yeah.
- [Woman] It's awful.
- It's awful?
Okay, we'll talk about tea.
Now these ones are flashing
as well, what is going on?
Has lightning struck the clock tower?
Is the DeLorean about to appear?
(audience laughing)
What's going on here?
You know what would be great?
If after this show someone goes, Chris,
the lights were fine
the whole way through,
the audience didn't know
what you were talking about,
you have a bleed on the brain.
(audience laughing)
I mean, really at this point,
I feel like we should
just do that cool thing
where they turn all the lights off,
everyone whips their phones out,
but your phones are all locked away.
But I've always dreamt
of doing that thing,
you know, like at a concert,
where they turn the lights down
and everyone's like "Get
your fucking phones out."
And everyone holds the torches,
and the person on stage is like, "Yeah."
And everyone else is like,
"This is inadequate lighting."
(audience laughing)
"Doesn't work."
I love that you came on to the stage,
turned this one off,
were like "This fucking does nothing."
(audience laughing)
Cool, I'm gonna try and time my punchlines
with the lights flashing,
or I'll do that cool
thing when they strobe
and people move on stage,
and it looks like they're
moving really quick.
Okay, we've drained the
light-based humor right now.
(audience laughing)
Some of you might think we drained it
about three minutes ago when it started,
but I am not an improvisational comic.
Well, yes, you announced
yourself on stage at that time.
(audience laughing)
I think it makes someone's job easier
when you provide running
commentary on it, doesn't it?
(audience laughing)
Just like, well that one's nailed it.
Be honest, ladies over here,
did you press something?
(audience laughing)
You have such cute eyes,
I'm going to walk away
before I get an erection in your face.
(audience laughing)
That is, see that's the
type of comedy you want,
and then the British man comes up,
and it's like, "Let's
talk about the queen."
We say, "God, save the
queen," that's what I was on.
(audience laughing)
Do I make it easier if I stand here?
No.
(audience laughing)
Done comedy a long time,
I'm trying to go through my mental Rolodex
of your now just making it more groovy.
(audience laughing)
If I could do a good
Travis Scott impression,
you know I'd be going "It's lit," yeah.
(audience laughing)
I don't know, it's a good way
to end the evening, isn't it?
Okay, I do have jokes.
(audience laughing)
I saw a man in a wheelchair
with one leg, that was a thing.
He was moving the wheelchair,
not with the wheels,
he was moving it by dragging himself
down the street with his one leg.
And obviously that is sad,
but I can't help what I thought, which is,
"Oh, that must be how he
wore the other leg down."
(audience laughing)
"Lighten up a bit, Chris."
Okay, yes.
It was all for the
purpose of a light pump.
(audience laughing)
Well, okay, right,
because the longer this goes on,
the more likely it is that someone
will actually froth at the
mouth and drop on the floor.
Let's start doing what I do to close,
which is a magical little
thing called freestyle rap,
that is rap that is made up on the spot
based entirely on suggestions.
(audience clapping)
Wow, you all just accepted that like,
"Yeah, fucking yeah,
"that's how any show should end, Chris,
"no matter who is on stage,
"this time it happens to be you."
So freestyle rap made up on the spot
based on whatever you want to rap about.
So everyone here think of a word, a topic,
or a phrase that you'd
like to hear a rap about.
There are some rules.
Number One, don't suggest food or animals,
it's too obvious and too boring.
Number Two, don't be too
unimaginative, be creative,
be, you know, esoteric if you wish.
Some of the best suggestions ever include
ninth century crop rotation,
and I had a German man who said
"A day in the life of
an Aztec high priest,"
so aim for that lofty peak, okay?
We'll get five suggestions.
I'm assuming that one of them will be
when the lights fuck up at a comedy show,
so don't worry, that's going in there.
Did someone put a hand up
when I was looking over here?
Is that you?
You putting your hand up very politely?
Or you're just showing off
that you've got bangles or something?
What would you like a
rap about, my friend?
- [Woman] Rumpelstiltskin.
- Rumpelstiltskin.
Okay, cool.
For those of you that don't know
the fairytale character,
that abducts babies.
It's quite quite a dark story.
"Guess my name?"
"Oh, this'll be fun."
"Or I'll steal your kid."
Okay, Rumpelstiltskin, great.
Rumpelstiltskin.
There's kind of a big group over here,
everyone over here, hello,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Woman] Income inequality.
- Income inequality, yes, yes.
When you were like, "I fucking hate tea,"
I wasn't expecting you to then be
like an income inequality person.
(audience laughing)
Rumpelstiltskin, income inequality, great.
Let's come to you guys over here.
Oh you, you're waving a candle around
like this is a Coldplay concert.
(audience laughing)
Fantastic stuff.
What would you like a
rap about over there?
- [Woman] Violin.
Violin, was that?
- [Woman] The instrument, the violin.
- The instrument, the violin.
What's the other definition
of the word violin
that you had to add?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, maybe, yeah.
Okay, cool, violin, great.
Middle of the room, we
haven't come to you,
what do you want a rap about?
(audience calling out)
Okay, well there were several.
Did you say "Andre Agassi's mullet"?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- That's yeah, no, he
did, he used to have hair.
(audience laughing)
Okay.
Wow, your voice sounds too young
to know when that was a thing.
(audience laughing)
Was he, who was, was he with Steffi Graf?
Who was his like missus?
- [Woman] Brook Shields.
- Brooke Shields was it?
I thought he was with
a tennis player, fuck.
- [Woman] Both!
- Both, at the same time?
What a player, yeah.
Okay, when was he with Brooke Shields?
That's the important thing to find out,
because there's a time
when it would have been inappropriate.
Let's, so Andre Agassi's
mullet, income inequality,
violins, and Rumpelstiltskin.
Final suggestion, let's get
it from the back of the room,
what do you want a rap about?
(audience member whooping)
Sorry, sorry, let's address the fact
that someone just kept
going "Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh."
(audience laughing)
The suggestion is someone being fingered
at the back of a comedy club,
that's what their suggestion is.
You were like, "Yeah,
the lights are dim enough
"that I can get away with it now."
(audience laughing)
Okay, cool.
Well, what I'm going to say is
whoever's trying to fix the lights,
obviously please don't
stop the lights being cool
when we actually drop a beat and have fun,
cause this is really the
most appropriate thing.
I feel I'm going to start and the lights
are going to go, "Nah, this is too white.
"This is not how we want to do."
I'm going to ask my band to lay me down
something groovy.
And we're going to freestyle
rap about Rumpelstiltskin,
about violins, income inequality,
Andre Agassi's mullet,
and getting fingered at the
back of the comedy show.
(audience clapping)
This is going to be thoroughly enjoyable,
and we'll start with you, cool.
♪ I ought to be aware ♪
♪ All these things I'm in the orchestra ♪
♪ I be picking all the strings ♪
♪ Let me tell you how I know ♪
♪ I do it Italian pizzicato ♪
♪ When they're there on
the floor on the violin ♪
♪ If you're on the first chair ♪
♪ I'll be sidling in, and I'm like ♪
♪ Ah, pleasure to meet you ♪
♪ Hello, what the hell was the
little cheer by the cellos ♪
♪ Over there, I'm a real mover ♪
♪ Prefer all the violins,
screw the tubas ♪
♪ I don't need those ♪
♪ The symphony would be
improved without the timpani ♪
♪ I'm just talking, their instructor ♪
♪ You've got the head bobbing ♪
♪ Looking like the conductor ♪
♪ Waving the wand, moving in the stick ♪
♪ Income equality is so sick ♪
♪ I really hate that these billionaires ♪
♪ They be on stage acting all silly ♪
♪ They don't even care about the people ♪
♪ Homeless with no money, no cash ♪
♪ It's really not funny
but we'll bring it there ♪
♪ In the rap anyway ♪
♪ We need to make sure that it goes away ♪
♪ Anyway, income equality I digress ♪
♪ How do you fix it,
legislation in Congress ♪
♪ That's the only answer ♪
♪ Relax, I'm not saying we
should increase the tax ♪
♪ On the middle classes
or the people working ♪
♪ I'm talking about the
billionaires who are deserting ♪
♪ They're like, "Hi,
I'm Jeff with the face ♪
♪ "I want to fly high,
going out to outer space" ♪
♪ That's the voice I do for Mr. Bezos ♪
♪ Weird little name just because ♪
♪ But the weirdest name
that we're slipping in ♪
♪ A tiny little dwarf
with a very cheeky grin ♪
♪ He's like, "Hello there ♪
♪ "Yes, I'll walk my
name's Rumpelstiltskin ♪
♪ "We should have a talk" ♪
♪ Well he wouldn't
introduce himself that way ♪
♪ Otherwise she would come
right back with the name ♪
♪ You can't have my
first born off the head ♪
♪ I think it was to do
with weaving thread ♪
♪ That was something from
the start of the story ♪
♪ Then it got weird,
got a little bit gory ♪
♪ "My name's Rumple, I'm really crazy ♪
♪ "Can't guess my name
then I'll take your baby ♪
♪ "And I run away, grabbing it with me" ♪
♪ Baby snatcher, like Agassi, ♪
♪ Andre cause Book Shields was under age ♪
♪ Maybe she was older at
this stage in their life ♪
♪ Used to have a lot of hair ♪
♪ And now he's got none,
a bald dome on there ♪
♪ He'd be walking shining,
reflecting in the sun ♪
♪ But in the 1980s, number one ♪
♪ Well not technically
that was Pete Sampras ♪
♪ On the little court,
yeah we got the answers ♪
♪ Party at the back, work in the front ♪
♪ Short hair, long hair,
mullet like a (beeping) ♪
♪ I apologize for even
saying those things ♪
♪ But you were over there
going like it stinks ♪
♪ The lights go down, and
it starts to shimmer ♪
♪ You're like we can get
sexy while it gets dimmer ♪
♪ You sidle up to the lady by the side ♪
♪ Saying long fingers,
do you mind if I slide ♪
♪ I can move them inside, yeah I do ♪
♪ I'm a cool dude, produce your own lube ♪
♪ When I start getting
tickling it around ♪
♪ Finger in there, yeah, it goes to town ♪
♪ That's nice I really like that sound ♪
♪ Got your fingers inside
in the village underground ♪
(audience screaming)